hey guys what's up I'm in Sundance
2009-10 oh are you doing hi are we gonna
get to announce the winner of the nikon
film festival yeah the only problem is I
already did it no but without me and
without rain yeah the rain guard here
and I forgot you're here so it hurts it
cuts to the bone well life is rough
hello everyone welcome to Sundance I
mean I guess this is Park to Utah where
sundance film festival is happening
right now i'm here with Chase Jarvis Oh
amazing judges of the nikon film
festival you're amazing judge and we're
both here to announce to you guys the
winners drumroll ginger ale penguin no
workout first thing one you were amazing
congratulations you telephone yeah i did
i just got the phone with him Marco it's
an amazing story he's a serbian refugee
now living in austin texas and he said
he's going to do some really great
things going to give a lot of that money
back to the community that helped him
make the film all right and let's not
forget our twenty-five-thousand-dollar
winner what's up cake did it a new drum
roll that was my drum roll that was a
badass bedroom I'll dremel you say and
and it's joshua new york state of mind
congratulations man's beautiful he's
doing his 25 grand he's gonna put it
back into the skateboard community he's
got a big history there he used to run
for 11 video magazine actually he wasn't
even a social media guy and he managed
she gets BAM and Tony Hawk just read
about his video
actually plan on going around sunday
yesterday asking people who difficult
win first thing one who do you think oh
that's not a contest yet a QP yet it oh
it's so much the chicken why are you
serious the chickens have large talons
yeah but this thing survives out in the
cold frigid temperatures see I dropped
him winner is anyway thanks so much for
everyone that entered and thank you so
much an icon for having some music
festival because you're giving
filmmakers like me out a professional
one a chance to really shine agreed I
big respect for you guys for an icon for
putting on the festival and not limiting
to any kind of format just about making
films and making short films and sharing
them I think that's really really cool
as a professional I have a ton of
respect for that so thank you guys very
much you're gonna make me look at my own
question I know maybe one of us has got
to be taller the other one's got to be
hi guys it's not from here sundance I'm
freezing it is cold but it is so much
fun and you should see this camera that
I'm shooting with because it seriously
it's crazy about this huge microphone on
top the nikon d300s I'm let me tell you
I look like a crazy person walking down
the street holding a tripod filling
myself
totally normal right totally normal just
a normal day here can I just jeans life
here at Sundance 2010 okay by doing win
in a fight I'd see the chicken why
they usually have talents distant i like
razor blades anywhere
the chicken chicken
I want to show you guys this amazing
view it's honestly so beautiful kind of
a beach person but let me tell you this
might have convinced me to think
otherwise that's don't like like whoever
is the onion to see rain milsons new
film skoda sure hey what's it about
what's it about what's it about telling
you have to convince I Spencer Susser I
directed the film hesher pressure is
about a 13 year old boy and his father
dealing with a tragic loss and this kind
of crazy and our kids who helps him do
it I had experienced a loss when I was
young so I ended up writing about that
not necessarily on purpose it just kind
of went there I just got out of the
movie huh sure and rainn wilson is in it
and it was pretty much an emotional
roller coaster after it was over I was
usually speechless I'm kind of
speechless right now it was one of those
movies where you watch it and you start
to laugh and then they start to cry then
you feel bad for laughing and then you
start crying again and I don't know it's
amazing definitely suggest it when it's
out thanks so much for hanging out with
me at Sundance I had such a fun time and
I've had a very cool time but it's been
really fun so hey either way it's been
awesome and congratulations again to the
nikon festival winners like crouching
down like I'm like getting all in your
face like up guys anyway ok I'm done I
need to go get warm before I I'm not
able to edit this because of bra spittin
yeah I have another video on my other
channel if you check that out more sun
dance clips
but I gotta get warm so